greeting of peace peace be unto you
thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the dean show
this week we're going to be talking
about the prophets
the prophets who were sent by the
creator of the heavens and earth
to teach us on how to get close to god
to teach us how to live
the prophets who we needed to emulate
and
today we have the last and final
messenger of sentence of mankind the
prophet muhammad peace and blessing be
upon him we are going to be talking
with our special friend our guest sheik
yusuf estes
we talked with him previously about the
first man the first prophet
adam now if you don't catch us live
on the tv here in chicago all of our
shows are online at thedeanshow.com
and you can go under use of estes and
see
the other shows that you missed now
without further delay we're going to
continue talking about the prophets
with our special guest sheikh youssef
estes when we come
back on the dean's show
jesus
thank you for being with us again sheik
it's great to be back
and is this building getting taller
every time i come here i don't know
and when you look out and you see
everything out there it's it's an
amazing thing
mashallah i like it and i like what
the studio is doing and i like the reach
that you're getting out to the people i
think that's what's really important
alhamdulillah
all thanks and praises to the creator
the heavens and earth allah who's given
us this ability
to be able to set up this dollar program
and we'd like to thank you for helping
to support
this dollar program that we're doing so
we can help benefit the world i'm just
wondering
on the next program when i come are you
guys going to have your own helicopter
and land on that helipad up on the top
because you bring me on that that'll be
cool
oh [ __ ] we talked about adam who was the
first
prophet and you talked about the story
what happened in the garden and some of
the other things how he turned to allah
alone he repented and people can go and
watch these episodes at thedeanshow.com
by the way i heard you mention the
website and i've been telling people
about your website
and they said well i went to
deanshow.com and i didn't find it i said
no no it's
the deanshow.com t-h-e-d-e-e-n-s-h-o-w
dot com yeah you have to put the word
the yes in front of it right
yes thedeenshow.com they can go there
and catch up
if they need to if they didn't catch if
they missed the other shows that we did
with you
tell us and continue talking about some
of the other prophets that god almighty
allah sent
to mankind i think it's good for us to
go back and
you know kind of pick up where we were
on the subject of special and super
special that you were talking about yes
a special person to us would be
one who is carrying a message an
important
statement for the people that message is
to worship god without any partners
but in english they will get confusing
because a messenger to us
and we'll use the word in the bible it's
used
is an epistle a message is an epistle
and one who cares it's an apostle yeah
but for us when we say the messenger of
allah this is called super
special let's give that message there
that he is a messenger in the sense that
he is
physically coming with something that
you can
touch yeah because
some of the prophets they came and they
told people to worship god but they
didn't come with a particular
scripture yeah or what's called sahoof
they did not come with that they just
came with the general
idea that worship god worship god
worship god
don't worship rocks stick stones bones
don't
worship things you see or don't see or
make up in your mind but
worship the only one god who created
everything in the first place
this is what they all said now this
would be for every single one of them
from
the beginning which would be adam all
the way to muhammad
peace and blessing be upon all of them
but when they come with scripture now
this is going to be more for the folks
who know about the bible
moses comes with the ten commandments
yeah
and not because it's carved in stone but
because it
is a new set of commandments for the
people
they said we didn't know about this okay
here it is and then
david or dawud this is called in arabic
and his son suleiman they have also
come with scripture called zaboor or
psalms yeah jesus christ peace and
blessing be upon him
he also came with something called the
injil
or the gospel or the good news yes
so each one of these is having something
there associated with them
more so than just a good character about
them
or just that they're saying just worship
god
there are many many prophets more than a
hundred and
i think 124 thousand more than so
tens of thousands of profits out here
yeah
and now
we have a distinction here between them
in that some are actually rasools
or umbia that have another nomenclature
and a distinction that they have this
this thing of uh here's a commandment
this is something to remember
and so on they originally came in the
form of
what was taught from mouth the
prophets hear it and they teach it some
of the prophets knew how to read and
write
now according to some old manuscripts
that we have
from jews christians some teachings of
early muslims they believe that adam of
course is the first of the all of the
mankind and also the first prophet
he has a son the name seth
or shith depending on how you pronounce
it
and he would be a prophet
in the sense that he's telling people
we're going to worship the god
that our father worshipped adam yes
to his offspring and so on then after
that
is going to come another one idris
enoch is how he's known in the bible
enoch
yeah there are some apocrypha from the
bible
in other words hidden from the public
these are hidden things but there is
a gospel or a a manuscript attributed to
enoch
enoch's teachings and so on and
it is also in islam to believe that
idris or enoch is the first man
who came with scripture that was written
that he was the first of all people to
read and write
about this it's mentioned in the quran
that allah says that
that it is a law who taught
man what he didn't know taught taught
the human being how to use a pen
and taught him what he didn't know and
it's said that this is talking about
enoch so this would be enoch would be
idris who's another prophet
after a prophet and a messenger and he's
an
anvia he's a nabi in other words he is a
plural of nabi
he's a nabi a prophet but he's also a
messenger because it was something where
he has something written down
something for the people to learn about
so it means that not only i guess that
it means that he not only
could read and write but also he had to
teach reading and writing to his people
if they were going to be able to carry
it forward
now we talked about our previous show
when you talked about adam
that he called people to surrender
submission sincerity obedience obedience
and peace
now what was the teachings and the way
of the next
prophet or messenger no prophet you said
idris and you how did you how did you
say his name idris
idris or enoch enoch what way of life
was he upon
the difference for all of them they
would all be saying to have the attitude
this thing that we're talking about to
recognize there's one god
this is monetism yes then what's your
relationship with him this would be
islam
so we believe as muslims that there was
always the
belief of at least some people believing
that there is
one god the god of adam that created
adam
and that god and and the understanding
of him
this is called hanef hanafiya hanif
to believe in this this is monotheism
yeah
then when people are talking about this
they're preaching a religion of
monotheism
or hanaf but when they come with some
commandment they said okay
and in addition to believing in god and
living in a subservient way to god
here's a commandment from god you have
to do this
okay that makes them a result that makes
them a messenger
so that's how we would say that
obviously
idris would be the first of those if
he's the first one reading the writing
and passing it on then it must be that
he's the first of the results yeah
what from authentic information do we
have
about the life of idris very little
very little yeah when i did the series
for the children called cassassolambia
the stories of the prophets we couldn't
even make a full program out of it
because
unless i really want to talk about
what's known from the apocrypha
if i want to talk about what's known
from the christians and what's known
from the the jews
about these i'm talking about the
scholars have information on that
but i didn't want to turn my program
into some scholarly work
about stuff but we don't even know if
it's authentic anyway
but i did want to reference that there
is somebody with this name
and he was a prophet and he had some
things now what he had
exactly if you want to compare what he
had to what let us say
for instance abraham had we don't have
enough comparison there to make a decent
uh
program out of it but we can conclude
that he worshipped god alone he didn't
worship the land he didn't worship jesus
every single prophet of almighty god
has to believe there's only one god and
they're trying their best to do
his will on earth as it is in heaven
this is that a foregone conclusion that
long sentence you just said
is summed up with one word in arabic
isn't it islam islam
okay islam is the verb islam would be
they were doing islam
they were submitting they were doing
islam islam
islam okay moving on we went from adam
idris
and now the next prophet or messenger
in line who was that there are many and
we won't know
all of them the ones that we know about
but key key yeah
he would be abraham alison peace be upon
abraham
abraham was also in the same area as
jonah he's in iraq now some might
offer that they might think that
that jonah would be older
but well no we did forget one didn't we
i did and that would be
uh obviously not a prophet in the sense
of being a messenger but definitely a
prophet in the sense of
calling the people to worship on god
would be noah noah
so no it then noah uh it could yeah it
would
be according to the genealogy mentioned
in the bible it would be
that noah comes after enoch
yeah and is how it's pronounced in
arabic
with the ha sound at the end was
one who worshipped god alone without any
partners
and he finds that his people though
they're
worshiping these statues yeah and how
that comes about is
that when there were these righteous
people before
and they died then the people would tell
the children you know you should be like
them you should be like them they were
righteous this guy or that guy so and so
so some of them made images or statues
of these people and said he looked like
this she looked like that i guess you
know
and then they would erect these statues
and people would pass by them and they
could say
well you know this person right here you
should be like this when he had this
good quality and that one had this good
quality
so people were identifying with these
statues in a way that
was to improve their character their
moral behavior their
their belief in god but then another
generation comes
they don't know what you're talking
about with statues they begin to worship
the statue itself
and so even you find this iconic
uh mindset today where people say well
i'm not really worshiping the statue
but i represent what i i worship what it
represents to me
yeah and so i'm not worshiping the
statue i'm worshiping the god that
dwells in the statue
or i'm worshiping the god who made the
statue
or i'm just worshiping god and the
statue reminds me of god
but all of these things are coming from
this mentality and this is what
noah came to get the people away from
yeah
and now another thing we didn't talk
about before about prophets
they come with signs yes those who come
with the major signs
these are major prophets
a major sign with noah was of course the
flood not because the water came up
because
anybody could say well it was a flood
yeah but the fact that he predicted it
in a time in a place where that had not
occurred before
and he kept telling it was going to
happen and you need to repent
you need to believe in god need to
turn your lives over to him and live
righteous because people were
really not very righteous at all at this
time
so what happens that when
he just builds this ark now the big ship
out there
they're dying laughing at him like what
are you building it here for
screwball you know look at you and then
he started bringing these animals and
putting him in there okay
this guy's whacked and they're making
fun of him laughing joking
his own son rejected to go with him and
that
yeah and in those days for sure there
was a big
family ties and it would be really
bizarre for you to disobey your father
but he's telling them come get in this
boat with them nah they're going to do
it
now he couldn't guide his own son so
this should tell all of us something
you can't force people to accept the
beliefs yeah
he couldn't do it we can't do it either
but you try your best to explain to them
and when the water started raising up he
told the sun come on get in get in he
said no i'm going to go up the mountain
he said it's going to go up there he
said i'll go higher up he said it's
going to top it off
oh it's never going to be that high
water doesn't go up to the top of a
mountain
are you crazy well we found out who's
crazy
because sure enough noah did get into
the ship
he did have the animals with him and he
had maybe had
70 or 80 people i don't know exactly how
many i didn't have
certainly didn't have the whole village
and the water came it came from above
and below this could be
rising water as well as rain coming down
it could have been
a number of things but it eventually
covered everything in their
area in islam we don't have this idea
that the whole entire
earth had to be covered with water for
so many days and nights or anything
but certainly the known world to him
was covered yeah they had a lot of water
there was a big flood
and reports that we have from some of
those who
archaeologists have told us that there
is evidence that in ancient times there
was a big flood that might have been
around the world
certainly it was in different places in
europe different places in arabia
this is known historically well yeah
there's definitely but there's been more
than one flood too yeah
and they might not be able to put them
all at the same time i don't know
yeah but if we make a contrast now
between what the bible says
the bible says that this was a worldwide
flood
and then the quran would say that it was
a local flood so would this
the quran doesn't say it doesn't try to
commit to that because the subject is
not
about how much water was covered yeah
it's about the fact that the people
themselves were covered with water
i see this is the point yeah so it
doesn't really matter to us
and we don't really care if it was all
covered fine and good if it wasn't
that's fine and good it doesn't matter
what matters is people didn't obey yes
they had a chance
they knew he was a righteous man he
wasn't lying
and then even when the water started
coming they could have said okay this
could be a sign let's just get in the
boat for fun
you know well they didn't yeah so
the main thing he did was he called them
to worship god and not these statues
idols
the people amongst themselves that they
had lifted up to the level of god
he called them something that was
natural to the worship of one god
yeah and and now it this is course of
testing them in a way
because you want me to worship on god
finding good
but now you're also asking me to believe
in a prophecy here that
water water's going to come up and that
would be a condition yeah you need to
believe that
so this is this is what happened at his
time
now later on we find that we'll go now
to abraham and
abraham his name is ibrahim this is the
next prophet now
messenger and he's going to be a key
prophet
super special if you will because he's a
rasool
and that he has actual scripture again
apocrypha teaches us
that abraham had some scripture yeah
but in the bible itself no we don't have
that but from islam we do know he did
because it says in quran
in surah atarik the end of it it says
the scriptures of abraham and moses
so we know he had scriptures so what
happened
and what was the unique circumstance
with abraham
you talked about noah and his unique
circumstance
what about abraham what was he well
battling at his time abraham's
father according to the bible is uh
terah
and his father
was a statue maker statue maker yeah he
made the statues that people worshiped
worshipped
big business also isn't it well it was a
actually a ministerial
post yeah that he in other words you're
not just a guy out here hustling
statues on the side of the road you're
making them by the royal command of the
king himself
at that time the king was named nimrod
or nimrud in arabic his name was nimrud
and he was the one who told people that
he was god actually said that he was the
lord
you need to worship him there's some
dialogue mentioned in the quran between
abraham and nimrod where in the the
just one example that abraham is
telling him that you should worship god
and he's saying well i'm god
he said no my god my lord
is the one who gives life and gives
death
now the story has it that nimrud brought
some people forward and ordered that
some be killed and then he spared the
others he said
those people lived and those died so i
give life and i give death
so then the response comes back well
my lord is the one who causes the sun to
rise in the east why don't you make it
come up in the west
no he's stumped yeah he's stumped that's
uh that's a good way to translate that
he was stumped and he couldn't answer
that of course he gets mad and
some other things happen but there's
another event that took place like this
that these people
worshipping these statues and abraham's
complaining to his father about these
statues why
why were you making these statues and
and you want people to
believe that there's a god in them i
mean you can make the statue have big
ears or big nose or
you know and it's up to you to tell tell
them that this is this god or that god
give it a name and
yeah and what's that his father of
course didn't want him talking like that
because
look i got a high post here i'm a big
shot and you're messing everything up
so at one point the people were out
doing something i don't remember this
that part of the story but so abraham
went in their temple
where all these gods these false statues
and idols were there
and he took a huge mallet a big hammer
like a sledgehammer and he began to beat
and
destroy all of these statues except the
biggest of all of them
and then he leaves the hammer the big
hammer right beside the big guy
yeah and then he goes away well when the
people return to the temple they're
amazed so what happened
what in the world who could do such a
thing and somebody said
bring that boy who's the son of the
statue maker bring him he's complaining
about our gods
so let's see what he has to say they
brought him and said look at this and he
looks around okay
said well what do you say about all this
he said why are you asking me
why don't you ask the guy with the big
hammer yeah
so at that stage they're like huh
well that's a good answer and then they
respond back to him said
he can't hear and he can't uh
see i can't hear and he can't speak i
think that's what he said
he can't hear and he can't speak he said
then why are you praying to him
that's a pretty good deal yeah and i've
asked people that have statues and
things that they hold on to
why do you why do you think this thing
can benefit you if it fell off and broke
what would you do they said i'll go buy
another one what is this
it doesn't make any sense so when he
did that though that's when they made
the big fire that one of the biggest
fires that was ever in history of humans
at that time
a whole valley full of fire i guess and
they wanted to burn him up
the king nimrod ordered to burn him up
but the people trying to build the fire
were averages
were themselves getting burned up trying
to build it wow they couldn't get close
enough to throw him in
and they developed then in their what's
called the catapult
you know the catapult yes this is that
long long long tree or bar
and you put a fulcrum here and then you
have a
balance there and then throw him into
the fire
well they did they threw him into the
fire with that catapult
but when he went in allah said be cool
for abraham
and they said for days and nights he was
in that fire
and he came out unscathed he had nothing
no burns nothing on him
and they didn't know what to do with him
after that they just want him to leave
now
this is a miracle right there wasn't it
it'd be a pretty big miracle
yeah now if we take it to modern times
he was fighting against idolatry calling
the people to worship the crater alone
the same thing noah did the same thing
idris did
the same thing the first man adam did
and if we look at modern times today
these were
icons these were statues you see some of
that
present today don't you in a different
form you see it in the exact same form
and other variants of it the exact same
form i have seen
in some countries i've visited people
have idols or statues i recall one
he had a statue on the dashboard of his
car he was a driver
and i got in and slammed the door and
when i did that
idol wiggled like that and i said what
is this he said that's my god
i said your what he said this is my god
for traveling
and put your seat belt on and as i was
putting my seatbelt on i said well don't
you put a seat belt on your god there
and he started laughing i said i'm not
joking i said
you know things wiggling there you're
allowed to hit a bump up here and it
falls down
you know and uh he said no it won't
watch and he grabbed it and he picked it
up and
you could hear he had velcro on it
i said a god with a velcro and then
he he put it back and what he did i said
well what would he do if it did fall
down
and broke he said i'll go buy another
one
so there's for some people they're not
catching that
what you're saying you're worshiping
you're giving prayers and thanksgiving
and requests
to a piece of wood or a piece of stone
for crying out loud
why do you think people don't see the
seriousness of this issue they'll walk
you'll walk in some grocery store and
you might see the icons of mary
or jesus they what they claim to be
jesus or
even you can put a quarter in one of
these little slot machines and something
will come out of a little small
statue and icon you see this going on
why
do people turn to these things why do
you think this is something that
attracts people
well muslims even have some of their own
problems too
as far as taking those little teeny
teeny qurans you can't even read them
yeah and they want to wear it as a
locket or something and it brings some
good luck
it's superstition people want something
they can hang on to to believe in
but they're not accepting that allah
himself is the one that really is
providing for you caring for you the one
you turn to the one you give
thanksgiving to
they don't want to do that because of
their various reasons
but it this is the biggest problem of
all this is the biggest
incorrect worship and incorrect belief
is what destroys the society
do you see this as just a cop-out an
easy way out
that i feel like i can do whatever i
want to do and then i
there's something yearning inside the
human being so he
takes this it could be for some people
eddie but i won't say that it's true of
everybody
it could be that that's the case but we
can't just write it all off and say
everybody's the same
let's bring in different reasons yeah so
before we conclude
tell us now what other
special event happened with abraham
and something that we can take home and
all benefit from
abraham was really i think a good
example for us
to realize that we can't identify god on
our own because he
had another example that he looked to
the sun to the moon and to the stars
and each along the way he said could
this be my god could this be
my god could this be my god but the sun
sets
the stars go away the moon the different
phases and
he says all of this is not my god and
the scholar said he did this for
for his people to hear him say it
because he knew better but he said that
you know this is not my god so i won't
be guided unless he guides me uh so we
should ask for guidance
absolutely and i'd like to thank you for
being with us great to do it
thank you we're going to have to
continue on talking about these
wonderful
human beings the prophets that we should
all emulate and
the last and final messenger but hold on
i want to give you an opportunity that
if somebody wants to learn more
you have some websites that you can
refer the people to i suggest
really that they visit our website
called shareislam.com.com
and on the drop down list on the left
you can look for it says prophets
or muhammad and check it out thank you
and thank you for being with us and a
wonderful
example of what abraham did peace be
upon him
he looked to the sun and said that can't
be my god to the stars into the moon he
said that can't be my god
and he asked the one god the creator who
created the sun
the moon the stars and everything in
creation he asked that god
to guide him and that's what we should
all do
ask the creator alone to guide us and we
hope to see you again next time here on
the dean show
until then assalamu alaikum peace be
unto you
foreign
foreign the dvd is for dawah as allah
has said in the quran in surah
16 125
invite all to the way of your lord with
wisdom
beautiful preaching and reason with them
in ways that are best
and this is a great opportunity for you
to take up
the obligation take up the call as allah
has told you to do
and share this beautiful message with
the world islam submission to the one
god
come and see what everyone's talking
about if you find one contradiction it
can't be from god
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
worshipping god is one i will never give
up spreading this message
i hope that you take that necessary step
you don't know if you're going to live
until tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now
if you say that you do not believe in
jesus you have stepped outside of islam
you cannot be a muslim is attending our
faith too
it's cold it's late
everybody's sleeping
i arise
and ask a lot to think in may
oh allah you see
oh allah you know
all the sins i do
i turn to you to forgive my sins and my
heart
i'm
me